eccolo whale sei pronto io ho fatto due
milioni store a bakwa sono sempre
arrivati in finale non ho mai vinto a
però dovremo vincere l'arrivo sempre in
finale da solo ma non vinco mai stavolta
vinciamo damanhur a nord
non so come funzioni ma lo so ma via via
che ti spiego via via allora dobbiamo
aspetta aspetta seta c'è il fuoco amico
ok perfetto allora qua ci sono le band e
le bende sacro servono solcato le
prendiamo
non so come si buttano a terra gli
oggetti non è da vieni qua c'è un
perotto prendilo e xi e xix se venite
anti di formato tutto aval vuol dire che
tu col perotto vedi il medico del fumo
keith altro spazio a spaccare qualche
arriva qua e per i primi corpi colpi
corpi sono questi quadrata che c'è un
percorso perfetto il per quattro
giornalisti ma sotto c'è un book air
vieni vinse qui sento spari senti
sparare
c'è gente però non sembra di una eco
occhio ai tom spara spara fatto sono
morti ma ti sto prendendo ci credo nei
passati due o tre bava prediletto bene
invitarti a questo gioco
bene bene a valutare bravissima ovvia da
6 plus è forse non ci facciamo io non ce
la faccio almeno sono gable e li vedo
occhio che loro non vedono te forse
perché non hanno altre quattro
a me hanno ucciso ad annunci di avere un
importante nei capito come si gioca se
per fare pronto e molto easy realtà però
è molto figo vai cerca 1 via si parte
subito qui vai vai vai c'è un po ubriaco
ha senso se no insomma si trovano gli
oggetti avrei dai per il pop il colpo è
molto forte la vicina ovviamente c'è
gente c'è gente arrivano li vedo
ma dai cribbio a si può bloccare
non lo sapevo per 4x4 vedi note che già
a palermo è sì non c'è niente che nel
caso ci sia cile stessa identità bisogno
di uno zaino ci sono dei colpi su due
piani di roba allora poi ci sarà un
bunker sicuro perfetto occhio si sente
così strano visto
ora vi tra gli atleti che botta occhio
che uscirà dal bunker tutta la vita
questo eccolo
niente
no sono ammonizioni no non ci si 20
forse solo allora ben d'occhio la safe
siamo in sei bene o se resistiamo in
questo momento ci curiamo ci riuniamo un
secondo ci siamo messi benissimo ho un
po max 10 dovremmo fare dai dai dai ton
questa è buona ok sono messo bene
anch'io dalle banche occidentali dal
bunker l'ho ucciso nello cisa raggiungi
la zona sicura andiamo possiamo dire no
per gente
no no 4 parco prende solo lui
l'occidente a destra mi chiama il
proprio diretto
minchia
sono solo un attimo è andato un andato
vieni pietra di pietro come saturando
una data 4 kg die die die liman con
sette ne mancano sette tom brava
nonostante di quei proiettili sti qua
non so neanche quali sono quelli della
mia arma di che colore sono e allora e
verdi sono chiara mai a k
non so perfetta può partire si alza
direttore allora allora è non lo so non
mi chiedere alla natura livello 2 è
visibile e invisibile poi ci son tanto
l'arma macomer invisibile area visivo
vera è visibile cerruti più visibile non
l'avevo mai visto gente qua sinistra
subito un casco che non serve la sua
modena e ne sto andando madonna e
bordello occhio lì è veramente pieno di
gente via via via si spacchi cessi non
so se ti dà qualcosa può essere o
apparire perché sono arrivato non è vero
tutti hanno lanciato le giornate
marancia guarda come lo prende dettato
un sacco di pugni ma porca vacca che
sperle porco con lo shock no signora non
lo è fatto niente
c'è uno zaino c'è niente zaino che
questo spara che ho una pistola
io non voglio niente la gente mi sciocca
amo dura di vita vabbè allora questi due
entrambi con l'elmo con lo shock con lo
zaino nero con gli accendini livello
iniziale come va
doppia pistola per lui arriva al
compagnia sempre liquore cliccando al
cambio ma come
ma se tu questo lo sparato a te per
un'ora e mezza
occhio che i preti rimbalzano e guarda
si è fatti loro
non so quiet e i proiettili credo tutto
meno 8 trovato subito under guardata
della minkia c'è gente fuori ancora la
stessa data anche gara
1 giu due giochi a destra
ricarico che aveva puntato gli occhi e
le strade sono lauro lo aveva cercato
becchiamo mercato però dai normale ecco
cos'è la casa comunista
non lo so per i luoghi comuni vedi
agiato l'errore comune di sto male non
lo sapevo non fosse logico lo sappiamo
se così pare non aversa traversa
manco e normandia lo sbarco eccoli
appena rimasto sbarco a north star
azioni e cosa fa quello scemo e scemo
mamma mia prima lady fatta la dorati
fucili a pompa sono fatti dalla chicco
volevano niente però tu hai mazza tutti
se mi resi mi dispiace sig
no problem continua rieccoli ora faremo
prima o poi a vincerlo vicino a me 1
allora c'è de vizzi dico che devi morire
dei morire e vabbè morte questo è un po
un po tutto strano per 4 1 ora di un
cavallo occhio no perché devo ricaricare
adesso ho preso anche preso non ci credo
oppure ok a terra terra per restare a
taratata il compagno non so dove sia ok
oracolo qual compagno
ecco le cose per farlo venire qua sta
male caviglia non si è fatto niente
bombardano morire dai non morire
preferita di dio
scusami sparo però torna vivo niente
ricarico no ma non rischia la lega
ricard che ci sono mi chiamino mela non
certo da minori morto ancora vivo ancora
lì ancora lì non ho più colonia è ancora
morta quale quando pensate a come fa uno
che appena iniziato la bari ed avere
così tanta roba guarda come pure gli
hacker cracker kg hackers per l'azione
di le mani nascondo quad empre mi curo
foto ballo non ha senso sta cosa c'è
gente cm ha sempre sempre con te la roba
capito e hanno colpito anche loro alla
casa nessuno all'apparenza direi nessuno
ma in realtà è colorata leggendo
uno è buttato giù lo ho buttato giù un
altro perfetto layer occhio diciamo
cazzate la figlia questo sto dentro la
fumogena io sto curando prima devo
morire tardi trova vicino arrivò poi
fuori dalla porta
occhio normale mi piace gli umani io
faccio pronti ha mai fatto male
ok per fare questo serve lo uso di
muoversi magia che ansia 7 in vita dai
debiti la soda se ce l'hai
se l'è presa regalino dai le pillole
paracetamolo 6 la tachipirina 500 se ci
sono quanto l'urto godendo ecco qua c'è
perotto e buono ho preso molto perche
vedo tutto qua non c'è niente il casco
livello 3 rubato molto bene oggi guarda
qua in basso a destra
tricarico perfetto aiutato ma non ci
credo
vittoria stasera si mangia pollo cosa
vuol dire ma cosa vuol dire si vola
si vola let's go mamma mia che ansia
provincia la partita anni bravo sia
uccisioni e squadra 8 quindi ragazzi
oggi grazie a tom e grazie a me in uniti
facciamo la vittoria portiamo alitalia
in alto nei giochi in 2d
ora vi sia piaciuto ragazzi considerando
gli piace alcuni social cominciata
descrizione anche al canale di instagram
di di thomas che sarebbe stato in
description sapersi gli schiavi noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video che stasera si
mangia pollo quello sapete già da
ragazzi
[Musica]